[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Patrick caner bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation bonne
année à vous sénateur du Nord président
du groupe socialiste ici au Sénat on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par Jefferson des
sports de Sud-Ouest bonjour Jefferson
bonjour bonjour Patrick canner bonjour à
vous on va commencer évidemment par
cette conférence de presse d'Emmanuel
Macron le chef de l'État qui s'exprimera
longuement ce soir à 20h15 depuis
l'Élysée dans un format il dit qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de sa prise de parole
déjà sur la forme euh c'est le retour de
l'ORTF quoi hein parce que 20h15 c'est
l'heure des foyers c'est l'heure du
foyer on se retrouve on mange il
s'impose dans tous les foyers français
toutes les chaînes confondues publ privé
enfin voilà ça va être le grand showud
Macron à cette occasion donc sur la
forme moi je suis assez c'est perplexe
hein sur une forme de d'autoritarisme du
président de la République qui décide
comme cela pendant 2h 2h30 3h on sait
que Monsieur Macron peut être long sur
un exercice on dit qu'il ne l'aime pas
on verra bien mais ce que je sais c'est
que moi qui ai assisté à plusieurs
conférences de presse de ce type avec
François Holland c'est ce que je c'est
ce que j'allais vous dire c'est
exactement le format que employait sauf
que ce n'était pas la même heure c'était
un petit peu plus
c'était l'après-midi avec des reprises
le soir par les télévisions les radios
la presse écrite là il
s'impose si c'est ça le grand
rendez-vous avec la nation qui a
commencé avec ses vœux avec le
remanimement la liquidation de Madame
borne la nomination de Monsieur
hatal voilà son son clone et qu'il se
poursuit avec cette conférence de presse
c'est surtout un exer
d'autojustification de Monsieur Macron
c'est un rendez-vous avec Emmanuel
Macron d'abord plus qu'un rendez-vous
avec la nation patri can je pense qu'il
veut se rassurer il veut se rassuré
parce qu'il n'a plus la il n'est plus à
la manœuvre un mauvais coup au Parlement
justement aussi et qui est à la manœuvre
si c'est pas lui déjà le Parlement les
mauvais coups SZ 23 493 avec Madame
borne bon donc les mauvais coups on les
a là on on dit on VO dans la presse ce
matin qu'il vaê plutôt utiliser la voie
rglementaire que la voie législative euh
donc le Parlement pour lui ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il ne le pratique plus et
quand il considère que c'est un
obstacle il faut l'évacuer il faut
l'évacuer c'est c'est grave pour la
démocratie parce que finalement on voit
bien à qui tout cela profite alors pour
revenir à votre question qui est à la
manœuvre euh il est à la manœuvre
euh mais il n'a plus les moyens
finalement de mettre en œuvre c'est sa
sa vision libérale de droite pour pour
le pays en en fait euh avec ce
gouvernement qui a été nommé euh on lui
on disait souvent mais il fait une
politique de de droite
euh mais euh il n'est ni de gauche ni de
gauche c'est je le disais ça souvent sur
votre plateau et maintenant j'ai envie
de dire il fait une politique de droite
euh et il est de droite et le droite au
moins les choses sont claires les
masques sont vraiment euh tombées Datti
votrein vrein Dati c'estes deux visions
de de la droite avec il a aussi Gabriel
hatal qui est issu du PS et qui le
premier ministre enfin Gabriel Attal est
issu du PS comme moi je suis curé quoi
euh oui il est issu du PS euh mais il
était il était d'abord il était d'abord
un conseiller technique de Marisol
Touren il a toujours vécu et en bonne
opportuniste qu'il est euh monsieur
hatal s'est très vite retrouvé auprès de
Monsieur Macron parce qu'il a avait vu
qui avait une faille au PS et cette
faille c'est c'est traduite y compris
par la non candidature de François
Hollande en décembre donc 2021
euh 2021 2016 ou oui j'aurais bien aimé
finalement mais bon ça n'a pas été le
cas donc tout ceci montre que nous avons
un resserrement du pouvoir avec un
Emmanuel Macron qui nomme Gabriel atthal
qui n'est même plus son collaborateur
c'est son supplétif aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça que je le je le conçois
monsieur Édouard Philippe a su créer sa
marque comme premier ministre notamment
avec la crise de la covid Jean Castex
devait gérer cette crise sanitaire et il
l'a fait avec son style pour rassurer
des Français madame borne bon certes
elle disait souvent ses fiches mais elle
avait quand même une certaine forme de
colonne vertébrale même si a pas pu
aller très très loin dans l'opposition
potentielle à monsieur le Président de
la République mais monsieur ATT
voilà pour vous ilimimera pas ah il peut
pas imprimer puisqu'il est au service
d'une seule conviction qui est celle de
son patron donc il va beaucoup
communiquer mais j'entendais monsieur
corbierre hier sur une une chaîne
concurrente député LFI dire faire
référence à l'ancien testament alors
pour Monsieur Cormia vous imaginez bien
il disait mais voilà qui qui gère sa vie
par le glève périra par le glève il il a
dit et c'est juste qui gère le pays par
la communication périra par la
communication pourtant est-ce que vous
attendez des annonces ce soir Patrick
canner parce que il y a plusieurs sujets
2 heur de presque 2 heur de conférence
de presse il va forcément quelque chose
est-ce que vous attendez des choses sur
le renouveau démocratique et les
institutions parce qu'on voit bien que
le cap économique est fixé les grands
travaux s'est fait avec Notre-Dame et
Villar scotter la cité de la langue
internationale française voilà est-ce
que c'est sur cet axe là que vous
attendez le président de la République
aujourd'hui la réforme des institutions
et du fonctionnement démocratique du d'
de notre pays ça fait 7 ans qu'il en
parle jamais traité jamais traité alors
le prétexte oui mais le Sénat n'en veut
pas bon il a surtout échoué à convaincre
il n'a pas pu convaincre ceux qui celles
et ceux qu'il faut convaincre à savoir
les parlementaires pour mettre en œuvre
la Constitution et et la réforme de
cette constitution bon alors qu'est-ce
que vous attendez sur les institutions
qu'est-ce que vous espérez en tout
casen la question du référendum la
proportionnelle sur du nombre de
parlementair le milfeul territorial dont
on parlait il y a quelques minutes les
bras je va prendre un exemple pour vous
montrer le caractère changeant du
président de la République euh en
2017 quand il est élu il décide de venir
une fois par an devant le Congrès pour
présenter la politique de la nation un
petit peu comme le rendez-vous du
président de la République aux
États-Unis devant le Congrès bon euh why
not il refait l'exercice 1 an plus tard
et en disant
euh je vais changer le mode opératoire
par la Constitution en permettant au
président de la République de pouvoir
assister aux réponses des présidents de
groupe puisque la tradition c'est que
les présidents de groupe s'expriment
après le président de la République mais
le président s'en va euh sans pouvoir
écouter en tout cas en direct
symboliquement les réponses des
présidents de de groupe il dit je vais
changer ça voilà ça n'a pas été fait il
n'y a aucune réforme qui a été lancée on
aurait pu imaginer des réformes
peut-être par petit bout la la fameuse
suppression de la Cour de Justice de la
République que tout le monde voilà
attend parce que c'est quand même qui a
relaxé éc Dupont morti oui mais mais
c'est pas parce qu'il ça a été relaxé
qu'il a été relaxé mais c'est parce que
tu une anomalie d'avoir une justice
d'exception pour les ministres les
ministres quand ils ont un problème il
doivent être jugé dans dans leur
fonction ministre par la justice de de
la République donc il y avait moyen
d'avancer sur certains points peut-être
moins ambitieux qu'initialement prévu la
réforme du du contenu du référendum
l'article 11 notamment en intégrant les
questions fiscales nous on aurait aimé
puisque on a été retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel voulant lancer un
référendum d'initiative partagé sur les
questions des super profits et le
conseil nous a dit non c'est pas dans le
champ du référendum donc passer votre
tour il y a rien à voir il y avait moyen
d'avancer il ne l'a pas fait il ne l'a
pas fait
je suis perplexe sur ses intentions
réelles ce soir Xavier yacobelli votre
collègue membre de la majorité
présidentielle qui était hier à l'Élysée
à la rencontre d'Emmanuel Macron dit
ancien socialiste oui ancien socialiste
a dit qu'il avait parlé du du
millefeuille territoriale sous-entendu
il y a trop de strat il faont supprimer
vous êtes d'accord avec
ça ce milfeu milfeuille il existe
mais vous savez je pense que les
Français se moque de savoir qui fait
quoi ce qu'ils veulent c'est que les
choses se fassent il a pas trop
d'échelon il peut sûrement y avoir plus
de travail de coopération
euh là aussi pour pour que nos auditeurs
comprennent bien les choses
euh on est dans une année sportive euh
cette année année année olympique la
compétence sport aujourd'hui est assumée
soit par les communes soit par les
départements soit par les régions moi je
pense qu'il serait utile qu'il y ait une
collectivité qui soit chef de fil de
cette compétence et là vous en rajoutez
une strate non je je dis simple je dis
simplement que il faut reflécher les
choses et sans forcément supimer faut
imaginer des blocs de cohérence euh
territorial un un autre exemple pour
vraiment parler au français
euh la santé est un sujet majeur dans
l'esprit des Français tous les sondages
le montrent euh la médecine scolaire en
France est dans un état lamentable
déplorable pourquoi ne pas confier cela
aux départements qui sont armés pour
pouvoir porter cette compétence donc
voilà ce que j'aimerais entendre de d'un
président de la République non pas des
grands principes mais des choses
concrètes qui changent la vie des
Français alors justement parmi les
choses concrètes si parle du pouvoir
d'achat moi je serais très content et
mais j'allais vous poser la question et
parmi les inquiétudes des Français
notamment il y a la hausse du prix de
l'électricité de 10 % qui est prévu au
1er février est-ce que vous attendez ce
soir du chef de l'État qu'il annonce
l'annulation de cette hausse oui oui oui
très très clairement parce que le
arrêtons de faire payer aux Français ce
qui pourrait être payé par
d'autres l'argent de ces disp de hausse
il suffit d'aller les chercher là où il
est le ministre de l'Économie arrête pas
de prévenir que le plus dur est devant
nous et que il y a cette hausse
notamment des prix d'électricité vous
savez combien de jamais prend contre son
ministre de l'Économie ce soir attendez
2023 93 milliards d'euros de de
dividende bon et ben s'il y en a un peu
moins et que ça permet aux Français
d'être de ne pas être taxé dans cette
période très difficile où l'inflation
est encore très forte elle va diminuer
tout le monde dit elle va passer en
dessous de 3 % bon très bien verra bien
je je le souhaite et on sait qu'il faut
un petit peu d'inflation pour faire
tourner l'économie mais pas à 5 ou 6 %
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui donc il y
a des choix politiques allez si on
enlève un peu
d'argent aux actionnaires de Total je ne
pense pas qu'ils souffriront énormément
au regard de la réalité de leur revenus
et ça permettra à des millions de
Français de vivre mieux en étant pas
taxé donc donc vous lu demandez de
renoncer à cette haosse mais je non
seulement je le demande mais s'il ne le
Pr on sait pas ce soir il confirmerait
ce que je le crains ce que je crains il
confirmerait l'engagement à droite et ce
dogme du moins d'impôt qui est toujours
présent dans les esprits mais c'est le
moins d'impôt pour ceux qui en payent et
et aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
Français qui risquent de payer 10 % de
plus pour le électricité et qui ne
payent aucun impôt un mot puisqu'on le
disait le chef de l'État s'exprime avant
le discours de politique général de
Gabriel Atal prévu la semaine prochaine
est-ce que ça choque pas ça c'est à vous
de me répondre ondre ça vous choque il
avait déjà fait avec Édouard Philippe il
avait déjà fait avec éedouard Philippe
euh Gabriel Atal bah tout à l'heure je
parlais de supplétif il va venir
peut-être mardi me dit-on devant
l'Assemblée devant devant le Sénat pour
présenter un discours de politique
général qui aura été complètement
élaboré par cette conférence de presse
donc on marche à l'envers non non non
parce que moi je suis respectueux
d'institution euh il y aura peut-être
des choses nouvelles complémentaires des
précisions qui seront apportées une
conférence après c'est un autre exercice
mais on voit bien où est le pouvoir quoi
Jupiter
ou le colosse
peut-être mais c'est pas une surprise
Pat caner après de presque de quin canin
c'est pas une surprise non ce n'est pas
une surprise mais estce que c'est pour
autant une bonne chose non je ne suis
pas surpris je suis inquiet pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions parce
que à force de lasser les parlementaires
alors bien sûr il y a les turiférraires
de Monsieur Macron qui continuont
toujours à dire qu'il est le meilleur le
plus intelligent le plus beau moi je ce
que je vois quand même c'est que de
gadget en gadget de de
d'imagination de grands débats aux
conventions citoyennes en passant par le
le Conseil national de de la rénovation
ou de la refondation plutôt de
rénovation les rencontres de Saint-Denis
les rencontres VO le Conclave le
conclave de Saint-Denis maintenant il y
a bon est-ce que vous arrêtez arrêtez de
euh caricaturer le bon fonctionnement de
la 5e République monsieur Macron n'est
pas de Gaulle il n'est pas mitéran voilà
il est un président qui a été élu par
défaut avec des voies de gauche et je
pense que il faudra lui rappeler à un
moment donné que s'il est là c'est parce
que des gens comme moi et des millions
comme moi ont voter pour lui pour faire
barrage au Front National et en fin de
compte le résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les populismes n'ont jamais été aussi
haut en France et que le Front national
avec le RN en tête de de de de piste
mais aussi nousouons pas reconquête
aujourd'hui pour les européenes pour les
européennes on est à plus de 30 % de
votes d'extrême droite c'est ça le
résultat politique des mesures de est-ce
que vous souhaitez que les socialistes
déposent une motion de censure si
Gabriel LAL ne soumet pas un vote de
confiance tout d'abord les socialistes
ne peuvent pas la déposer tout seul ils
sont pas assez nombreux maisf a déjà dit
qu'il la déposeraitilà p capacité de lap
il est normal que est-ce que vous vous
associerez à celle de la France ça c'est
à nos collègues députés d'en décider
mais il sera asszm vous en avez parlé
avec Boris Vall votre mais il sera assez
normal effectivement que la gauche se
rassemble pour dire non alors pas pas
laanupes laanupè aujourd'hui vous bien
être entre parenthèses mais il y a des
groupes de gauche qui
existent à l'Assemblée nationale et il
faut déposer une motion de censure même
s'il n'y a pas de vote de confiance
alors peut-être qu'il demandera
finalement V de confiance que j'ai
entendu monsieur cotti dire ni confi
défiance voilà donc arithmétiquement il
pourrait demander la confiance mais tout
ceci
vous souitez qu'il fasse du coup on
amuse on amuse on amuse bah c'estàd que
ça sert à rien ni le vote de confiance
ni la motion de censure du coup puisque
les aler ne vot ni l'un ni l'autre
certes ça ne sert à rien sauf avoir une
expression politique devant les Français
tout ne peut pas se résumer à la
conférence de presse de Monsieur Macron
fa parler des groupes de gauche Patrick
canner on est on parle d'un possible
sission au sein de la majorité avec un
possible groupe de gauche chez les
macronist à l'Assemblée comment vous
regardez
ça il y a un an et demi je crois je
faisais une tribune dans le JDD à
l'époque où le JDD était encore le JDD
le Journal du
Dimanche appelant les macronistes de
gauche sincère de gauche à ouvrir les
yeux et à se dire mais ce gouvernement
pratique une politique libérale de plus
en plus à droite ce n'est pas la réforme
des retraite et encore moins la loi sur
l'immigration qui me fera dire le
contraire mais ils sont toujours dans la
majorité est-ce qu'ils auront un jour le
courage et peut-être même la conscience
euh de dire mais ce n'est plus possible
euh enfin moi je serais macroniste de
gauche territoire de progrès euh il y
avait un des leaders de territoire de
progrès qui était à ma place il y a
quelques euh minutes ancien socialiste
vous le rappelez ancien socialiste et de
l'aile gauche de mon groupe en plus donc
comme quoi tout est possible
euh accepter que Madame daty qui est
vraiment la droit du et une droite
caricaturale rentre au gouvernement
comme si de rien
était c'est pas un gouvernement Macron
c'est un gouvernement Sarco Sarco 3
Sarco 4 Sarco 5 je n'en sais rien mais
c'est c'est Sarco qui est au pouvoir
mais du coup est-ce que vous appelez les
députés socialistes il y en a qui ne
sont pas sur la ligne d'Olivier fort et
et de d'une alliance avec la France
insoumise à créé un groupe avec ses
macronistes de gauche ah moi je suis
resté au PS c'est pas pour marchander
quoi que ce soit si des député
macroniste estime issu notamment de
territoire de progrès estime que ça va
trop loin et que encore une fois ce
gouvernement de droitees pratique une
politique de droite avec un président de
la République de droite qu'ils en tire
les conséquences qu'il se retirre de la
majorité est-ce qu'il crée un groupe
spécifique ou est-ce qu'il rejoignent le
groupe lot qui est un groupe
intermédiaire ou directement le groupe
socialiste ou voir les Verts peu importe
on dire ça c'est leur responsabilité est
drotisation du gouvernement c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour le Parti
socialiste est-ce que c'est pas une
occasion pour vous de renaître sur de
nouvelles bases et de récupérer ces
électeurs de gauche qui étaient partis
chez Emmanuel Macron si j'en lis les
sondages pour les européennes ça semble
être une bonne nouvelle puisque nous
sommes sur le podium avec Raphael
gluxman à 9 et demi 10 % alors c'est pas
non plus des chiffres
extraordinaires mais quand on vient de
là où on vient aujourd'hui on est
content bon très bien donc oui il
semblerait qu'il y a une prise de
conscience
et que peut-être les élections
européennes vont constituer le début
peut-être de ce retour à la place
centrale de la social déémocratie de de
cette gauche de responsabilité de de
gouvernement comme l'on dit
souvent mais moi je suis pour le clivage
droite gauche non mais est-ce est-ce que
pour que le PS en profite répondre mais
moi je suis pour le clivage droite
gauche c'est l'antidote à l'extrême
droite et au populisme
les choses au moins sont claires et et
c'est la respiration démocratique au
travers de l'alternance potentielle
monsieur Macron a voulu tout effacer
éclater les toutes les références en
disant ni droite ni gauche en même temps
le ruissellement tout ça c'est moi tout
tout passe autour de moi et le résultat
c'est quoi c'est qu'il est 10 points
derrière 10 points derrière et nommé àal
pour faire de l'antibardela mais c'est
pas le boulot d'un d'un Premier ministre
Premier ministre il est là pour mener la
politique de la nation il est pas là
pour être
de la majorité est-ce que ouais et juste
est-ce que Patrick canner est-ce que
pour que le PS en profite il faut
qu'Olivier fort acte dès maintenant une
rupture franche avec la France insoumise
mais elle est actée cette rupture il y a
un moratoire c'est pas une rupture oui
bon enfin vous avez quand même bien vu
que même si euh ETF souhaiteraient
encore une liste unique avec nous tout
ça c'est derrière nous donc non mais
audelà des européenes si vous voulez
reconstruire après est-ce qu'il faut
acter dès maintenant la rupture avec la
France ah je je je moi à titre personnel
je considère que LFI est un parti
politique important dominant aujourd'hui
encore à gauche qu'il y a eu quand même
des événements qui ont montré que cette
dominance ou cette
domination était quand même assez
artificielle excusez-moi nous somm ici
Public Sénat il n'y a pas de sénateur et
des filles la gauche n'est pas
représentée par les sénateurs et les
filles parce qu'il y a pas eu d'ENT
Patrick canard parce que au niveau des
sénatoriales le PS a fermé toutes les
portes à double tour parce fille mais
non parce queelle est fille n'a aucun
aucune implantation territoriale
donnez-moi le nom d'un d'un maire d'un
grand-maire et les filles en France d'un
président de département et les filles
donc c'est un colosse au pied d'argile
et les filles ils ont effectivement une
tête pensante et agissante qui est bien
sûr Jean Mélenchon il y a un corps
idéologique qui est réel mais
l'implantation territoriale elle est
inexistante donc nous nous avons cette
force de cette implantation territoriale
et nous l'avons démontré donc
rééquilibrage à partir des sénatoriales
rééquilibrage à partir des européennes
et on continuera comme ça
euh cela ce n'est pas dire que LFI n'a
pas sa place dans la vie politique
française c'est dire que et je l'ai
toujours dit ce que je ne pense pas
qu'fi puissent mener la gauchchee
pouvoir un mot sur la puisque vous avez
été ministre des sport vous l'avez
rappelé Patrick hanner sur la polémique
lancée par Amélie Castera ministre des
Sports désormais ministre des sport et
de l'éducation nationale sur la
justification qu'elle a fait de la
scolarisation de ses enfants dans le
privé elle appelle hier à clore le
chapitre des attaque personnelle est-ce
qu'elle peut rester en poste pour
vous encore une fois la la question vous
savez laissons un peu de temps au
produit quoi on verra bien ce qu'elle
donnera comme comme ministre mais elle a
très mal commencé c'est c'était vraiment
une une entame désastreuse il y a pas
désastreuse il y a pas d'autrre mot
absurde de de répondre à la polémique
comme elle a fait elle avait elle avait
pas à répondre c'est un choix personnel
qui qui relève de C privé elle a répondu
ça c'est une première première erreur
deuxièmement quand on est ministre on
défend d'abord sa boutique elle ne l'a
pas fait
donc absurde de répondre très maladroit
pour le moins
de absurde aussi de rajouter au
portefeuille de la minist des sport
celui de l'éducation nationale j
reviendrai si vous voulez bien et et
troisème élément donc absurde de
répondre
maladroit de s'attaquer à sa propre
administration à son propre ministère et
troisème élément
irresonsable de mentir ilr elle a menti
alors est-ce qu'elle a menti par
omission parce qu'elle a menti par
confusion mais elle a menti
objectivement et et la réponse à ce
mensonge c'est d'aller tout à l'heure si
j'ai bien compris à l'école litrée enfin
je dire je sais pas quiécole publique de
son secteur je pense qu'il faut qu'elle
sa qu'elle sache qui est son responsable
de la communication hein parce que alors
là on a tout faux et moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai eu des conversations j'ai travaillé
avec Madame ou ctera puisque j'ai porté
le dossier des j 2 ans au gouvernement
de chez François Hollande avec Manuel
Vals et Bernard 19
euh c'est une honnêtement c'était un un
autre niveau que le raflcel ù je le dis
hein brutalement mais ro je le dis
brutalement et et au moin c'est clair et
mais c'est trop tard c'est trop tard
pour notamment les résultat
sportif ce qui est terrible c'est que si
elle reste Ministre en charge notamment
de l'éducation nationale elle va avoir
sûrement un ministre délégé ou un
secréire d'État en charge des Jos mais
changer comme ça d'équipe et je sais ce
que ça veut dire d'avoir un secrétariat
d'État il faut il faut garder un lien il
faut pas sur faire de ce vous dit c'est
qu'on peut pas faire les deux en année
olympique en France on peut faire les
deux mais pas en année olympique voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est
que et moi je pense que le ministère des
Sports est un ministère quasiment
régalien et moi je me suis toujours
battu pour qu'il ne soit pas noyé noyé
dans le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale donc je regrette cette
décision avec une ministre qui
manifestement n'était pas préparé à
occuper une telle
merci patri merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci Jefferson la
de sudouest c'est parcours les clés pour
être admis tout à fait pour tout savoir
sur parcours et c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci on passe au club des
territoire